the rain is gone and we're just about
ready for baseball as zach pleisek makes
his way in from the
tribe bullpen he'll be starting tonight
for cleveland
in the series opener coming off a very
good start against the white sox where
he matched up with
lucas giolito he went five and two
thirds innings gave up three hits didn't
allow a run walk four struck out six
first pitch fastball is grounded to
short ahmed rosario a routine play
one down nick castiano's no slouch
hitting 324.
good there's your ground ball chart
right there
beautiful one two three go the reds take
on
wade miley yeah miley the perfect guy to
pitch when you have an hour plus rain
delay because he'll get you back on
schedule
here as best as anybody five stars three
and two record good earned run average
and that is picture perfect oh what a
frame job
and miley slams the spot another payoff
that's a good pitch
it's a weak pop reaching swing
this miley guy knows what he's doing huh
so far
so good one two three in the opening
crane
that'll bring up tucker barnhart easy
play to end the inning for josh naylor
in the tribe
no score middle of the second now faces
from reyes
and that is on the inner edge strike
three
two k's for miley both looking
might have broken his bat there nice
play by farmer
takes mustaches off the bag and he makes
the tag
so top of the order two on nobody out no
score
nick senzel the batter there it is
double play
cesar steps on the bag but they can't
turn two
all right first and third now you got a
tough hitter up there jesse winker
runner goes 3-2 hit hard there's one
and they can't get it out of the glove
they do turn to double play though
somehow rosario finally found the handle
and an ending ending double play
even with the runner moving on the pitch
miley goes to work now against josh
naylor
he went no need for appeal
there's the breaking ball from miley in
his third strikeout
one out and that'll bring up ahmed
rosario
swing at a miss a change in the dirt
and miley is cooking with gas and now
he'll get the catcher austin hedges
right back to miley he could pick it too
no
base runners for wade miley through
three
three four and five due up nick
castillanos
and that one is poked deep left center
hits the base of the wall
castillanos claims to a stand-up double
for the reds right fielder and with only
one out
reds have a scoring opportunity here as
they did last inning
got him looking oh just at the top of
the strike zone with a slider second
strikeout in the game
by please sack and now he goes to work
on his former teammate tyler naquin
swung out and missed he challenged him
with a high fastball
and police sack strikes him up so the
reds have stranded another in scoring
position
cesar hernandez has grounded out to
short
weak round ball pickett moose
here's jordan luplow wade miley is far
from average tonight
swing into this it's five strikeouts
jose ramirez has popped a third
now he works down off speed lost by
suarez the throw
still in time hey eugenio suarez
recovers
and wade miley still perfect tucker
barnhart the batter
swing and a miss boy i'll tell you what
zach please has struck out three in a
row that gives him four on the night
one away in the fifth inning of this
scoreless game and here comes kyle
farmer to the plate
slow chopper to third ramirez racing in
has to unload in a hurry
and he does to get him josh naylor he
looks like a goalie down there at first
base as he goes into that
stretch position two down for shogo
akiyama
weak ground ball hit to third ramirez
got him reds go in order for the second
time tonight
no score halfway through facing front of
bill reyes
it's been 12 up 12 down for miley
farmer to his feet slower runner makes
the play
now here's eddie rosario flew out to the
right fielder his first time up 2-2
swing and a miss rosario kind of
stepping toward first
stuck his backside out as he flailed at
that pitch he had no chance
wade miley harold ramirez
breaking ball to third suarez five
perfect innings wade miley
has been sensational that'll bring up
nick castiano's
one for two with a double center field
harold one two three go the reds that's
nine in a row retired by police act but
wade miley
has been picture perfect there's a
ground ball and two hops to nick sintel
the second baseman fields and throws out
josh naylor for out number one
in the sixth ahmed rosario
backhand loss senzelle from his knees
bounces away from mustaches
and ahmed rosario becomes the first base
runner of the night
for the indians we'll see if that'll be
scored a hit
or if that is an error that's a heck of
an effort by senzel to knock that ball
down
so no perfect game but still a no-hitter
evidently
so austin hedges with a runner at second
round it back to miley
looks back rosario nice job two down
it's now two on two out and an all or
nothing hitter in jordan loophole
right at shogo akiyama wade miley
strands a pair
he has a no no throw six mike mustaches
the clean up hitters flight out grounded
out
slow hook got him looking nothing he
could do he just
could not pull the trigger and that's
ten in a row for police act
and now tyler naquin makes his way to
home point police
so one pitch swung on another weak
bouncer to first
bobble by naylor recovers backhand and
flip click kept his foot on the bag good
stretch
adding is over a no-no that's in
progress for wade miley he has been
stellar what a good pitch right there
molly shook off the curve ball came in
with the cutter
and ramirez gets a strikeout that'll
bring up front mill reyes
back to miley
two down in the seventh now he'll tangle
with eddie rosario
ground ball gobbled farmer
no hitter through seven wade miley
cruising in cleveland well zach please
sack
is locked in some kind of pitchers duel
tonight
threw it by him seven k's for flea sack
13 in a row
and shogo akiyama the number nine hitter
in a ground ball to short ahmed rosario
throws him out
you can't say enough about the gutty
performance tonight by zach policek
still scoreless wade miley the fourth
reds pitcher to carry a no-no into the
eighth inning
in the last decade
ground ball zenzel
and the batter is josh naylor broken
back
since el challenged one footed throw and
he makes it
two down eighth inning now ahmed rosario
who can fly he was the first cleveland
man to reach
ground ball again farmer
wade miley with a no no through eight
infield hit by since el line drive
single left by winker
and here is nick castianos grounded
right side
gathered by clase offline throw senzelle
rounds 30 scores
winker over to third base and the reds
on top
one to nothing when cossay got the ball
back to him
he's assuming that his shortstop is
going to be coming across the bag but
he's not
he never really even gets there he kind
of plays behind the base right there so
when clase throws it to him he's a good
six or seven feet away from second base
and now mike mustakas who's over three
take off from first base by the time
klossa steps off he boxes another run
winker scores it's two to nothing
hard ground ball gets through wave is on
for castellanos
that ball dies in the gap on the grass
castellano scores mustaches delivers
a three run ninth three
to nothing it has been a mountain of
ground ball outs 106 pitches
one walk seven k's wade miley
three outs away
in the air to right two outs away cesar
hernandez
go for two with a walk oh two strike
three
and miley is one out away jordan loop
blows oh for three
ground ball farmer
wizardry from wade miley a no-hitter
and baseball history